tributes for a 17 year old boy called
nayel who was shot dead by police during
a traffic check on Tuesday in the Paris
suburb of nonteur this woman says her
sons knew the victim they can't believe
what happened
they're in shock they said Mom what
should we do what's happening with the
police these days are they protecting us
or do we need to be protected from the
police
the teenager was driving on this road
when he was stopped by police they say
he was about to run over a police
officer who opened fire in self-defense
but another version of events soon
emerged someone walking across this
bridge at the time filmed what happened
on their mobile phone and that video
tells a very different story the car
stationary a police officer points a gun
at the driver
anger over the shooting sparked on rest
overnight in nante and in a number of
other Paris suburbs and cities including
Bordeaux and Lyon the French government
says justice will be served and called
for calm the police officers been placed
under investigation for involuntary
homicide on a visit to Marseille the
French president said nothing Justified
the death of a young person
we sent all the nations faults in
solidarity to his family and Adolescent
has been killed it is an acceptable and
inexcusable
last year a record 13 people were killed
in France during police traffic checks
Niels is the second such death this year
campaigners have long railed against
what they say is widespread police
brutality in France videos like this
they say a vital proof of what so often
goes unseen Natasha Butler Al Jazeera
nantar France